احتجاج تلو واحتجاج يتعظم المد الثوري ضد
النظام الايراني
يتصاعد هذه الاصوات الغاضبه ويعلوا الضغط
الدولي الرافض لقمع المتظاهرين ليزداد
الخناق يوما بعد يوم فيما يبحث النظام عن
مخرج او قل مفر من ازماته الداخليه
الخارقه تلك
هنا تطل ورقه التصعيد النووي املا في صرف
او تحويل الانذار عما يدور داخليا تصعيد
يقابله الغرب برؤيه مواكبه لمجريات
التضارات الشعبيه تلك المانيا تتفق مع
امريكا بشان التركيز على ملف حقوق الانسان
بدلا من الملف النووي لكنهران ومع ارتفاع
حده الغضب الداخلي ترفع مستوى تخصيب
اليورانيوم في منشاه فورد بنسبه 60% كما
تدش يوسن سلسلتين من اجهزه الطرد المركزي
وهو اذا التصعيد النووي لكن ليس ذلك فحسب
بل ورقه الاخرى تلقي بها ايران صناعه
لاحداث في موازات ما يحدث من تظاهرات لا
تهدى
الاعتقالات حيث اعتقل النظام 40 اجنبيا
دون الكشف عن جنسياتهم متهما اياهم
بالضلوع في الاحتجاجات التي اشعلها مقتل
مهسا اميلي دون تقديم ادله عن ذلك الاتهام
اوراق متعدده ترمي بها طهران وبكل ثقلها
مع التعمق ازماتها الداخليه
واتساع دائره التظاهرات المناهضه للنظام